Yeah.
How many without booze,
boy,
that would be a struggle.
That would suck.
I mean,
our whole job is entertaining drinkers.
I wonder what it would be like if we had liquor free comedy nights.
Have you played,
you have to have played like those we'd rooms.
Yes.
Those are too crazy or insane.
We did the Toronto one.
The underground room.
Yup.
There was no air for the candles on the table.
The candles were running on a promissory note.
Yeah.
There was no oxygen in the room.
It was all just weed smoke.
I was onstage midway through jokes and having second thoughts like every linear
thought was a tree branch that was growing where I'm like,
which one?
White follow.
Well,
not only that,
what did I already talk about?
Yes.
What am I,
what am I covered?
All right.
I have no fucking idea.
Do you guys know?
Well,
when I was doing it was doing it with Tripoli and Tripoli was sober at the time.
Okay.
But we walk in this room and the secondhand smoke is a fucking real thing.
That's what I mean.
I hadn't hit a joy going to wait until after my set.
I don't like doing comedy high and I felt I felt high on stage and it's that
thing where it's like,
well,
you just got to run with it.
You can't,
you can't fight the tide.
Don't swim upstream.
You're not getting any better.
No,
you just got to keep going.
Ah,
I did.
There's a show that a guy,
Andy Haynes had called midnight run where you'd smoke right before he got on
stage and you just hit this big joint and I was doing great and then I had this
huge setup and then my brain just the bottom fell out.
Everything fell out,
all ideas,
all thoughts,
my name and I just went.
It was like,
and then the girl turns to me,
I've got to go and I walked in the middle of a set up and then it was a crushed
any cause people were laughing so hard because I just pulled the ripcord.
I literally was like,
I had a parachute that came out my backpack that pulled me out of the room.
Sometimes marijuana is your friend,
and sometimes it will fuck up your whole set,
but sometimes it'll go,
why?
Why is that?
Then people go,
yeah,
why is that?
And then you're off on this tangent that you probably would have never been on.
And that tangent might be the best part of that set.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think about people that were like,
uh,
from very regimented backgrounds and went into the military,
you know,
in the 60s,
and then hit their first joint and went,
this is dumb.
Yeah,
I hate this.
What do they,
cause that's the thing about,
I found it about marijuana is it introduced true.
There's about myself that I found hard to face.
Uh,
and they were maneuver my new truth.
They weren't anything big that I,
that I was afraid of or something,
you know,
that like,
I really want to kill someone or something stupid.
But it was just little things that would like bubble up.
And I think that's,
that's,
that's the craziest thing about that plant to me.
Well,
the idea that it makes you paranoid,
right?
That's it.
It's the paranoia,
right?
Oh,
I don't like pot.
It makes me paranoid.
I really think it makes you hyper aware of all sorts of things you've been
suppressing.
That's it.
Because when I'm feeling good,
when I'm happy,
like I've been a good person.
I've been nice to,
people have done the things I'm supposed to do.
I can get high and I enjoy the shit out of it.
But when I got loose ends [inaudible] I got things that are fucking with me,
you know?
Maybe like something that went wrong in my life or whatever,
and then I smoked pot and then it just gets weird.